show me ID so military ID Jack Jess so
if we're porting for booze you don't
look like this guy this guy looks like a
soldier I'm really excited to go camping
with you guys
why doesn't he bag stop going through my
[ __ ] Sarah wait did you not tell them
that we were coming I was I'm telling
them now like they're learning of it
right now Jeremy said within the next
six miles into the woods can't you
something dude the fun you came condom
this might be your chance to be with
Becky
she's always happening for you I'm slow
playing it okay you are know playing it
nice spring break and I'm ready to rage
let the games begin
[Music]
if you want we can make down no no I'm
not gonna take the long way down I'm
gonna take the Shawn way down
I honestly didn't hurt that much it's
actually really fun this knife is so
sharp what is she doing
did you just oh no no no what I have a
medical emergency I need a medevac
poncho I'll get their attention the
fireball was all me did [ __ ] idiot
that was insane Wow the fun King you
wanted to use it at the hospital
[Music]
it was just supposed to be kept me Shawn
look up yeah where's your problem trying
to you boner what I'm a bony did you
just fart no it's a seat oh my god do
you have the farts and a boner
I don't have the farts or a boner one of
those is definitely alive you'll be in
cock-blocked literally buy your own
clock
[Music]